bonjour c'est cyprien oui je sais ça
fait assez longtemps que j'ai pas fait
de vidéo pour mon blog ça fait depuis
quoi depuis 2004 quand même il ya
quelques semaines j'ai changé
d'appartement 6,6 et d'ailleurs je vais
vous livrer ma technique pour avoir un
appartement sur paris pour avoir un
appartement sur paris c'est extrêmement
simple il suffit d'une seule chose
beaucoup de chance
avant j'habitais dans 1 20 mètre carré à
deux temps lève la salle de bains et les
meubles il te reste coi un mètre carré
d'espacé vital c'est bien un mètre carré
excuse moi je crois que ta chaise et
dans mon espace vital si si en fait j'ai
compté les planches du parquet temps à 7
et j'en ai cinq d'ailleurs pour se
rendre compte de l'état du marché
immobilier à paris
c'était très capital comme phrase ça
se rendre compte de l'état du marché de
l'immobilier à paris
bref pour se rendre compte du délire il
fallait être là pendant l'état des lieux
demande ans un studio qui a duré cinq
minutes pendant lesquelles il ya eu
trois visites en visitant cinq minutes
alors que le studio n'était pas encore
aux locations ont davantage c'est que le
studio était tellement petit que les
visites ça allait plutôt vie excuse moi
c'est bien ici la visite tiendra le
toutim peur c'est que parfois les gens
ils prenaient des photos
et mon studio je vais prendre quelques
photos en fait c'est bon mais je suis
bien content depuis habiter dans cette
pièce parce que en plus de l'espace
vital relativement restreint suis quand
même quand même et les murs étaient
composés de commander un une sorte de
feuille de calque en fait un
quand mes voisins parler j'avais
l'impression d'être dans la conversation
le dimanche
non j'ai plus de farine non plus désolé
alors j'écoute ça donne quoi le vent ils
pensent qu'on lui parle euros non mais
j'entends tout en fait l'entente tout ce
qu'on dit quand le blaireau il faut
savoir que les propriétaires sont les
gens les plus paranos au monde devant le
gamin de sixième sens qui voit les morts
ils te font signer un milliard
d'assurance pour être sûr que tu vas
bien payer son loyer moi on m'a fait
signer un papier qui m'oblige à à payer
mon loyer
même après une catastrophe naturelle du
type météorite qui tombe et extinctions
d'espèces ul non juste au cas où la hd
comme c'est quoi ces papiers alors
qu'est-ce que j'ai signé et tout ça
c'est terminé maintenant j'ai déménagé
attention j'ai une baignoire samedi de
mon espace vital d'avant
et comme vous pouvez le remarquer j'ai
très peu de décoration sefa très prêt
personnel tout ça je le pensais bon
d'accord j'habite dans un showroom ikea
j'ai des cadres avec rien dedans je ne
connais pas cette personne je n'ai pas
de chat non plus maintenant j'ai un
petit problème avec cet appartement ou
au niveau de la serrure à chaque fois
que je vois ça je me dis pourquoi
pourquoi peut-être que l'ancien
locataire était un
c'était un lutin d'ailleurs s'expliquer
pourquoi j'ai un balcon mono personnel
peut-être qu'il y mettez toute sa
famille de lutins sur ce balcon je sais
pas bon c'est tout ce que je veux vous
dire j'ai pas de page facebook mais j'ai
un compte twitter et un blog bien aussi
non
et